bonsoir nous sommes le mardi 24 novembre
merci de nous retrouver pour cette
nouvelle édition du 7 8 le journal comme
chaque jour nous revenons sur votre
actualité locale entouré de nous inviter
mais aussi des journalistes de la
rédaction
on commence tout de suite avec les
titres de cette édition face au handicap
les entreprises parfois dépourvu ce
matin le club fasse de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines proposait
d'écouter des témoignages et d'obtenir
des conseils pratiques
retour sur ce rendez vous demain
mercredi journée de mobilisation autour
des violences faites aux femmes à
travers la france et ce constat le 39 19
ligne d'information téléphonique
national destiné aux victimes a traité
plus de cinquante mille appels l'an
dernier soit deux fois plus que l'année
précédente en plateau hélène colombier
directrice du centre d'accueil
equinox à montigny le bretonneux et
enfin l'occasion de la sortie de son 24e
roman le crime du conte neuville amélie
nothomb s'est prêté à une séance de
dédicaces à la librairie le pavé dans la
mare à elancourt c'était l'unique rendez
vous prévus dans toute la région
parisienne sensibiliser le monde de
l'entreprise au handicap c'est un des
objectifs de l'association face ce matin
à trappes
elle organisait une matinée de
sensibilisation dans le cadre d'une
politique de diversité différents
acteurs du monde du handicap ont
rencontré des chefs d'entreprise pour
partager leurs expériences
l'objectif échanger sur cette question
légale autour d'une table ronde mais
aussi comprendre les besoins et
difficultés que peuvent rencontrer ces
personnes
un reportage de william l je pense que
ça c'est 50 cent
55e
l'habituel vrai qu'on utilise beaucoup
de visuellement ce sont des gestes que
nous exécutons tous les jours et qui
nous paraissent simples mais qui peuvent
être un véritable obstacle pour une
personne atteinte d'un handicap qu'on
laisse à vos délires un texte voir un
film au cinéma et même commandé un petit
déjeuner par exemple le sucre qui colle
aux dents equipo décarie donc au monde
comme ça ici qu'on a des caries après on
a la trouille est oui c'est très très
imagé l'objectif de porter concept c'est
de mettre en place des actifs des
activités des animations de
sensibilisation au handicap tout
simplement de faire tomber les barrières
entre personnes valides et personnes en
situation de handicap et notamment dans
l'entreprise a surtout le mérite
principal c'est de savoir comment qu'on
pense au quotidien cette
personnalisation de handicap au niveau
de l'accessibilité au niveau des
transports au niveau de sa vie
quotidienne à comprendre les difficultés
d'une personne atteinte d'un handicap
c'était l'un des objectifs de cette
matinée de sensibilisation organisée par
le club fasse mais aussi répondre aux
questions pratiques des entrepreneurs
sur le sujet il ya une barrière
psychologique du salarié qui refuse son
handicap et comment arriver à surmonter
cette barrière par l'environnement des
partenaires tels que le médecin du
travail le préventeurs en entreprise
l'ergonome l'infirmière ou la personne
qui est chargé de mission handicap en
entreprise il s'est échangé identifier
les freins et comment essayer de trouver
les leviers nécessaires pour une bonne
intégration et un bon maintien dans
l'emploi des personnes qui sont en
situation de handicap des témoignages
d'entreprises pratiquants l'emploi de
ces personnes handicapées ont été
entendus par les chefs d'entreprise
présents
une manière de convaincre et d'apporter
les outils nécessaires à l'application
de cette politique pour mes propres
interventions et propre coaching avec
paris ça me permet de leur donner des
éléments de réassurance d exemple
concret et c'est au delà de la dimension
humaine
effectivement de la personne et aussi le
regard des autres est effectivement
changé ses représentations face à
l'antiqua depuis dix ans les dispositifs
légaux ont permis un accroissement du
nombre de travailleurs handicapés en
entreprise
des journées comme celles ci permettent
l'accompagnement de l'entreprise pour
favoriser l'intégration durable du
salarié au sein des équipes et demain
mercredi 25 novembre c'est la journée
internationale contre les violences
faites aux femmes ou journée
internationale pour l'élimination de la
violence à l'égard des femmes pour en
parler avec nous en plateau hélène
colombier bonsoir et niçois d'avoir
répondu à notre invitation
vous êtes la directrice du centre
d'hébergement et de réinsertion sociale
l'équinox à montigny-le-bretonneux
également est un sel vous vous occupez
donc de l'étain ses pieds c'est un
accueil de jour pour les fans donc un
victimes de violences alors tout d'abord
nous avons eu cette information
l'association fédérale nationale
solidarité femmes a publié lundi 23
novembre donc hier son bilan annuel
et les chiffres sont toujours aussi
accablant en 2014 le 39 19 violences fin
faut donc la ligne d'information
national destiné aux femmes victimes de
violence a reçu deux fois plus d'appels
que l'année précédente c'est à dire 50
1780 hélène colombier la situation des
femmes est ce qu'elle s'aggrave selon
vous alors c'est difficile de répondre
comme ça cette question en tout cas ce
que l'on peut dire c'est qu'il ya une
mobilisation une offre qui est présente
sur le territoire
je pense que beaucoup de femmes qui ne
venaient pas jusqu alors maintenant font
des démarches donc peut-être que on veut
voir un signe d'amélioration
effectivement dans cette démarche de de
résilience sinon de mobilisation en tout
cas d'informations de la part de ces
femmes c'est ce que vous percevez avec
est un fait dont il y en ait que deux
jours qui a ouvert le feu en avril 2014
en afrique c'est ça en avril puisque
depuis donc nous avons sept mois
maintenant des médecins aux parents le
soir du 15 07 -
d'activité nous avons accueilli plus de
300 femmes ce qui est un chiffre
important la plupart reviennent plus de
huit fois ça représente 71 famille
mobilisés sur le territoire donc c'est
un chiffre quand même relativement
important rapporté à la jeunesse de
cette structure
alors justement à ces fameux qui a donc
sont en situation très difficile
comment ça se passe et on les oriente
c'est la police les oriente vers vous on
commence à s'organiser un petit peu
alors pas uniquement la police sont
l'ensemble des partenaires
majoritairement les services sociaux de
droit comment du département également
les partenaires beaucoup d'associations
aussi qui oeuvrent déjà sur le
territoire
et effectivement les intervenants
sociaux de commissariats et des
gendarmeries qui a eu son mot à dire
dans les situations de crise en contact
avec ces femmes donc les prescripteurs
prescripteurs pardon peuvent être
nombreux pour les orienter vers
l'étincelle donc demain c'est vraiment
c'est l'occasion aussi de rappeler donc
les violences faites aux hommes qui sont
un vrai un vrai problème
difficile aussi à régler quelles sont
par exemple les solutions que pour les
femmes qui se retrouvent dans ces
situations là les solutions pour
justement peut-être en sortir comment
vous voulez conseiller quand vous les
orientez alors déjà nous leur apportons
des informations elle peut venir de
façon libre anonyme et gratuite
cherchait déjà des informations
les demandes sont nombreuses ça peut
être venir chercher des informations sur
leurs démarches ça peut être venir
chercher du soutien de l' écoute de
l'information après on peut proposer
effectivement de l'hébergement des
solutions je dirais c'est du cas par cas
et ça dépend des demandes bien
évidemment c'est une situation qui
touche toutes les femmes et ces femmes
toutes les femmes toutes les couches
sociales oui ça nous le savons il n'y a
pas de
2 2 comment dire de population de public
particulier effectivement la violence
est un phénomène qui touche toutes les
strates de la société quels que soient
les milieux sociaux beaucoup de travail
donc ce n'est pas un phénomène isolé qui
touchent spécifiquement un public déjà
vulnérables vous devez combattre
certains clichés je pense auxquels vous
êtes confrontés sans étincelle par
exemple où ils sein de certaines femmes
qui mieux qu'elle peut être confronté
qui viennent ce qu'elle n'ose pas
peut-être venir vers vous elles sont
incapables peut-être vraiment trouvé une
victime pour pouvoir en parler
ben c'est tout le travail est là tout le
travail de les informer de leur apporter
des informations
je pense que on ne les juge pas déjà
elle peut venir de façon libre on ne les
oblige pas ni à déposer plainte ni à
faire des demandes et des démarches si
elle ne le souhaite pas je pense que au
final la décision leur appartient ils
font un temps chacun doit avoir un temps
différent pour pour faire sans son
propre parcours donc demain il ya cette
journée on avait également beaucoup de
campagnes publicitaires de prévention de
communication sur ce sujet pour pousser
les femmes justement à sortir de leur
silence
selon vous est-ce que c'est suffisant
est ce qu'on en parle assez c'est un
sujet de société la barre suffisamment
on en parle de manière récurrente et
régulière dirait suffisamment non parce
que déjà est ce qui est important c'est
d'avoir de diffuser des informations un
petit peu partout donc après je pense
que de plus en plus il ya des actions de
sensibilisation qui sont faites auprès
des professionnels maintenance cette
thématique là est intégrée dans toutes
les formations des professionnels que ce
soit dans la police des travailleurs
sociaux des professionnels de santé
donc je pense que appartement on va
sensibiliser de plus en plus les
professionnels
on peut espérer qu'il y aura une
mobilisation une détection en tout cas
plus précoce de ces personnes qui sont
finalement victime est ce que si vous
appelez peut-être enfin il ya un
problème des gens qui sont être témoin
de cette situation et qui n en parle pas
testé ça aussi à une chose qu'on va
mobiliser la violence reste un sujet
tabou
les violences sont majoritairement soit
conjugal pour 90% d'entre elles pour ce
que nous voyons soit intrafamiliales
dont bien évidemment l'auteur des
victimes est toujours approche donc ce
qui rend d'autant plus difficile les
relations la dénonciation par les enjeux
qui se passe au sein d'une fratrie au
niveau de la cellule familiale donc bien
évidemment ça reste un sujet tabou pour
la famille est honteux aussi pour la
personne qui est victime
demain vous organisez donc à l'occasion
de sa journée une zone un peu spécifique
donc est-ce que vous pouvez nous en dire
quelques mots qu'est ce qu'il va se
passer demain justement centre-ville est
en fait oui alors demain effectivement
nous avons une journée un petit peu de
célébration de fêtes puisque nous
organisons une sorte de journée portes
ouvertes qui se déroulera de 10 de 10h
pardon à 16h30 avec des animations des
ateliers bien-être à destination des
femmes a suivi d'un buffet pour celles
qui sont déjà inscrits pour l'ade suivi
d'un ciné débat et ensuite on finira par
une pause détente pour célébrer ensemble
la cette libération de la femme cette ce
parcours d'émancipation voilà donc
demain c'est pour nous un une journée
dédiée aux femmes qui peuvent venir de
façon libre encore une fois à
l'étincelle
donc c'est ouvert à tout le monde c'est
ouvert à tout le moins d'absolument donc
le centre d'accueil de kiel deux jours
pleins devant le centre d'accueil de
jour est un sel donc c'est comme un
succès vous avez quand même accueilli
beaucoup de beaucoup de gens ont ça
montre son efficacité que je vois c'est
quelque chose qui est assez a demandé
parce que vous avez peut-être la volonté
justement d'ouvrir d'autres centres
comme celui ci pour accueillir des
familles en situation alors la demande
de l'état a été d'ouvrir un accueil de
jour départementale donc pour l'heure
nous en restons là
néanmoins nous avons eu nous travaillons
avec énormément de partenaires sur le
territoire et nous essayons l'un d'eux
notre lune de notre mission l'un d'eux
nous rôle est de mobiliser
et de rayonner et de faire du lien
justement avec les partenaires qui sont
déjà mobilisés sur l'ensemble du
département et nous disposons de
logements qui permettent de protéger les
femmes sur l'ensemble du département
voilà pour répondre à votre question au
niveau gouvernemental c'est une question
et c'est qu'ils étaient pris au sérieux
on en parle de plus en plus c'est
suffisamment pris au sérieux selon vous
il ya encore des efforts à faire je
suppose je pense que ça la lutte contre
les violences faites aux femmes a déjà
été érigée au niveau d'une politique
publique donc je pense que c'est déjà un
bon plan nous avons des plans
interministérielle qui se succèdent
maintenant la question cruciale est
celle des moyens financiers
je pense que c'est le cas aussi pour de
nombreuses politiques qui bien
évidemment appellerait un soutien
financier plus pérenne et plus important
bien évidemment
merci beaucoup et hélène colombier donc
je le rappelle de mails à cette journée
vous organisez plein d'événements plein
d'initiatives pour la journée contre les
violences faites aux femmes si vous
voulez plus de renseignements
voilà cette adresse www.ch rsc équinoxe
point fr enfin sachez qu'ils également
en parallèle de cette journée donc
contre les violences faites aux femmes
la journée internationale des droits de
l'enfant sera célébrée également le 25
novembre à la verrière à partir de 9
heures une journée organisée par
l'association enfants du petit pays on
pas en fond du petit pays en partenariat
avec amnesty international donc ce sera
l'occasion de célébrer de proposer une
journée de sensibilisation pour que le
respect de droits de l'enfant soit une
réalité au quotidien c'est une journée
ouverte aux scolaires ou périscolaires
également à tout public
enfin avez-vous déjà entendu parler du
don pâtissier elle a débuté cette
journée cette opération a débuté hier à
versailles une initiative bourg monde
est solidaire en partenariat avec le
secours populaire
l'idée quand une personne achète quatre
éclair au chocolat par exemple la valeur
d'un éclair et récolté pour permettre
aux enfants démunis des yvelines
d'assister à une sortie de noël les
précisions avec camille lambert une
solidarité gourmande se met en place à
versailles venir en aide aux plus
démunis tout en se régalant c'est l'idée
de l'opération le don pâtissier objectif
pour 4 est clair acheter la valeur d'un
de ses éclairs sera ensuite reversée au
secours populaire partenaires de
l'opération
le secours populaire était plutôt
enthousiaste on avait déjà
collaborer sur un ennemi un épisode de
top chef pour envoyer des enfants en
vacances
il savait déjà que j'avais des idées un
peu fofolle et que mais que je les mener
à terme
l'argent collecté financera une sortie
de noël au cirque pour des enfants issus
de familles défavorisées des yvelines
une idée qui a séduit une quinzaine de
boulangerie de la cité royale
c'est alexandra qu'est venu me voir qui
m'a demandé si elle souhaitait
participer à cette belle opération
ça nous fait aussi une petite opération
commerciale bien sûr donc quand
quelqu'un va nous acheter un éclair on
lui proposera forcément le don pâtissier
commencé le 23 la première édition du
thon pâtissiers se termine lundi 30
novembre l'association lydon gourmand à
l'origine du projet envisage déjà une
seconde édition l'an prochain mais cette
fois à l'échelle de la région
et comme à chaque mardi d'un journal
nous parlons à présent un politique
bonsoir wilfried bonsoir flore année à
moins d'une dizaine de jours maintenant
du premier tour des régionales la
situation est pour le moins particulière
certaines formations comme le parti
socialiste ont décidé de suspendre leur
campagne d'autres en revanche comme les
républicains pour suivre l es rencontres
sur le terrain mais on parle plus
officiellement de meeting alors les
attentats ont profondément bousculé le
déroulé à de la campagne ils sont aucun
doute les intentions de vote et la
manque
le premier sondage poste attentats pour
notre région a été réalisé par
l'institut ipsos est le premier constat
le front national progresse de 2 points
1 22% d'intentions de vote au premier
tour pour la formation menée par
vallerand de saint-just c est autant que
claude bartolone qui lui aussi
progressent d'ailleurs pour les
socialistes de 1% une progression aux
dépens de ses anciens alliés de gauche
les verts et le front de gauche sont en
recul quant aux républicains et il
recule légèrement de 1% mais valérie
pécresse garde beaucoup d' avance 33% au
premier tour elle s'imposerait même au
second toujours selon l'institut ipsos
avec 40% devant le ps 36% et 3e le front
national 24% alors au total treize
listes se présentent en ile de france on
imagine que les plus petites formations
ont encore plus de mal à exister avec
les allemands qui se sont passées en
france moins d'un pour cent d'intentions
de vote notamment pour la liste
fédération libertaire unitaire ouverte
conduite dans les yvelines par laurent
carieuse bonsoir bonsoir c'est d'être
revenu sur ce plateau aujourd'hui pour
vous
exister au milieu des ténors est-ce que
c'est compliqué de par notamment les
événements qui se sont déroulés à paris
bientôt une cafétéria du tout compliqué
lapointe c'est que vous m'avez agité ce
qui prouve quand même pas quelque part
dans ce pays est allé personnes des
femmes et les hommes qui sont quand même
pour une autre possibilité face donc la
nomenklatura
je profite juste une demi seconde pour
envoyer un message de sympathie aux
parents de mes colistiers 2014 qui a été
tuée au bataclan
voyez vous et vous dire qu'en fait petit
ou grand parti nous avons aussi donc
toutes les problématiques
on va parler votre liste liste assez
atypique elle rassemble syndicats des
prostituées le parti pirate qui se bat
pour la liberté informatique ou encore
cannabis sans frontières tout ça sous la
houlette de sylvain de smet qui est un
conseiller régional il a été élu aux
régionales en 2010 sous l'étiquette
europe écologie elle les verts et
d'ailleurs vous même vous étiez candidat
aux législatives en 2012 notamment sous
l'étiquette gauche républicaine et
citoyenne alors autour de quoi autour de
quelles valeurs et de quel programme
vous avez réussi à vous mettre d'accord
avant d'aller quand même la réponse je
vous dirais que vous avez commencé quand
même par quelques éléments qui font
partie de ce groupe
il faut savoir que le groupe il est
beaucoup plus hétéroclites que ça vous
avez pas vu qu'ils avaient donc déjà
très large engis bien entendu mais je
dis je viens quand même à préciser qu'il
n'y a pas que cannabis aux frontières ni
non plus je ne sais plus ce que vous
avez dit oui à partir du mouv rien le
savoir ça quand même vos alliés
inattendus ou quoi je vous dirai
pourquoi c'est qu'à partir du moment où
nous sommes quand même à cette thèse
nous oublions d'eau clos notre
particularité c'est fluo
voyez-vous fédération libertaire
unitaire est ouverte niveau et moi je
pense que ça je vous dis même pas d'où
je viens et je sais où je vais vous avez
justement
eh bien nous allons g important pour
vous aujourd'hui que vous avez planté
avec ses 19 ans ceci étant tout ceci
étant dans la mesure où nous avons une
modification très importante division
vous avez vu nous avons des méga la
région actuellement en france et on
semble aller vers ce qui existe dans les
pays
le gouverneur comme l'allemagne ou alors
comme les spas etc
nous nous disant qu'il faudrait quand
même apporter quelques éléments
supplémentaires pour qu'on puisse avoir
des régions autonomes parce que aller à
l'autonomie avec un état qui continue
donc à jouer donc le centralisateur
ce n'est pas très très fiable et donc
nous est fellow nous voulons quand même
rassemblé les femmes et les hommes de
toutes origines de toutes tendances mais
l'essentiel c'est que ces personnes là
se trouve quelque part exclu loyer vous
de ce qui se passe en ce moment exclue
de larmes au décisionnel et nous voulons
justement c'est pour changer la
politique faire en sorte que toutes ces
personnes quelles que soient leurs
origines quelles que soient leurs
idéologies quel que soit ce qu'elle
souhaite c'est que ces personnes se
réunissent ensemble pour faire avancer
le bateau france donc c'est porter la
voix des exclus vous êtes la liste qui
défend dès aujourd'hui les exclus les
déçus aussi de la politique luiz mais
sans lui les déçus parce que je crois
que dans ce pays il y a quand même
beaucoup plus d'exclus autres guillemets
que deux personnes qui sont satisfaites
moi j'ai été me rejoindre et vous tout à
fait et même la génération
j'étais pas je me sentais exclus parce
que j'aurai la politique différemment je
vois faire autre chose et donc si vous
voulez c'est parce que nous avons fait
une réflexion très importante qui nous a
permis de dire que si vous changez pas
certaines choses et en particulier la
façon colère de nous comporter face aux
électeurs
nous risquerions pour être des décennies
et décennies de rester dans la même
situation
la volonté c'est de faire de la région
ile de france une région pilote avec une
feuille de route le trépied qui est fort
mais je vous cite un par la démocratie
locale la transparence dans l'action et
le respect de l'environnement
tu l'as fait c'est très large c'est à
dire ça fonctionne comment cette région
pilote cette région pilote qui doit
ramon avait apporté le lard
la phrase paupières lé nez pas très
large il ya un trépied le trépied c'est
d'abord et avant tout la démocratie
directe
donc on peut va me dire aujourd'hui
quelle démocratie directe en face il y
en a eu
sous les athéniens mais on a plus ça
veut dire quoi plus de référendum ce
looser 09
locaux plus eu de consensus plus de
discussions plus de le rapport avec le
citoyen qui en fait est le site et le
souveraine la légitimité c'est bien mais
il faut quand même penser que nous avons
un souverain qui nous a envoyés pour
pour faire quelque chose
nous devons revenir vers lui
régulièrement vous lui donnez vos cours
pour tenir au courant de ce que nous
faisons deuxièmement le deuxième arbre
nous avons donc dit ceci étant il ya la
transparence transparence voyez-vous qui
va de pair avec la démocratie locale
c'est de montrer où s'ouvrait moudre et
donc à ceux qui nous ont élus ce que
nous faisons et pourquoi nous le faisons
pair avec la main le premier point est
le dernier c'est le respect de
l'environnement la sensibilité
écologiste demande fait l'écologie
n'appartient pas aux écologistes clos
j'y apporterai tout citoyenne j'ai pas
dis que ça dépend des d'europe écologie
les verts j'ai eu la sensibilité
écologiste alors moi je dis ça parce que
vous savez avec le com 21e avec tout ce
qui se passe avec tous les problèmes que
nous avons bien je crois que il faudrait
vraiment être un grand fou que d'oublier
que l'écologie c'est l'élément central
voyez vous voulez décennies parce que je
ne parle pas pour moi ni pour mes
contemporains mais je pense aux autres
vraie voix ce qui vient qui viennent qui
viendront après comme nous avons tous
ces problèmes qui se passe au niveau de
la planète
je crois qu'il est peut-être temps qu'un
parti digne de ce nom
enfin soyez vous de l'écologie son socle
majeur et un dernier point aujourd'hui
c'est la première élection pour fluo
pour votre rassemblement c'est une
première étape
c'est une première étape fluo va
perdurer vous poursuivrez lieux et
appelez voyez-vous à poursuivre puisque
ces tuyaux ajustement des idées
particulières ils sont je pense unique
n'est ce pas dans le paysage politique
et de par ce fait je crois que quels que
soient les résultats des élections fluo
devrait continuer merci laurent caruso
tête de liste yvelines pour cette
formation fluo qui se présente en ile de
france et l'une des treize listes
candidates
merci à vous merci wilfried on retrouve
juste après ce journal pour une nouvelle
édition du 7 8 politique entretient à
suivre avec claude bartelone et david
douillet tout autre sujet à présent
vendredi soir amélie nothomb ou la
célèbre écrivaine a fait son unique
séance de dédicaces au pavé dans la mare
à elancourt
son nouveau et 24e roman le crime du
conte neuville c'est aussi son premier
polar plus de 200 fidèles lecteurs sont
venus parfois de très loin pour voir à
l'écrivaine regardez ce reportage a
signé ses formes à manille elle l'a
reconnu dès leur première rencontre sans
même l'avoir jamais vu deux ans qu
amélie nothomb b alexandra colin
apprennent à se connaître à travers leur
correspondance
la littérature est un moyen de
rencontrer l'autre en conservant les
vertus de la solitude disait proust
j'ai de très bons lecteurs qui me laisse
profondément et au départ il y a
toujours le livre après ça dépasse
considérablement le livre ça prouve bien
que un livre en fait c'est un tremplin
c'est un lien quand la littérature
atteindre son but et devient un vrai
moyen de communication entre les êtres
et sans doute le plus profond si vous
prenez tous ses livres un parent que
vous les mettez vous tabou vous avez la
vie d'amélie en fin de compte c est un
trait puzzle est juste qu'elle se livre
à chaque fois un petit peu après vingt
trois ans de sollicitations amélie
nothomb ben offrait enfin vendredi
dernier à la librairie le pavé de la
mare d'elancourt son unique séance de
dédicaces en région parisienne pour le
crime du comte de neuville ça fait 23
ans que je publie des livres ça fait 23
ans que le pavé dans la mare n'invite ça
fait rien de trois ans que je dis non et
ils sont toujours là c'est comme un
prétendant extrêmement fidèles qu'on a
avec qui on a été odieuse pendant vingt
trois ans on se dit mais il m'aime
toujours allant voir ça de plus près 24e
roman et premier vrai polar d'amylin
tombe une réflexion sur le destin
considérer inéluctable à la manière des
tragédies grecques
une écriture accessible et l'humour
toujours au rendez vous j'ai toujours
été vraiment très mauvais en français et
puis un jour j'ai on va dire découvert
ces bouquins notamment c'est écrit sur
le japon
et ça m'a donné envie de savoir un
minimum écrire correctement français je
tombais amoureuse de son écriture de ce
qu'elle raconte son humour d'originalité
enfin chez moi c'est une vraie
découverte
quand on ouvre à nouveau amélie nothomb
on sait jamais où ça va aller trois
heures de séances de dédicaces 200
personnes rassemblées pour échanger sur
l'écriture intime de cette femme de
lettres belge grand prix du roman de
l'académie française 1999 et prix de
flore 2007
autre sujet à présent placomusophiles
cela pourrait être notre mot du jour
ça ne vous dit peut-être rien un
placomusophiles est une personne qui
collectionne les capsules de champagne
ce week end à magny les hameaux se
tenait le 9e salon des placomusophiles
mélanie poker camille landais et camille
lambert nous en dise plus ces capsules
vous n'y faites sans doute pas attention
eux la concert avec précaution ici il
n'est pas question d'achat ou d'argent
la règle celle échange il ya un
catalogue qui répertorie toutes les
capsules qui existent encore environ
40000 et il ya une cote sur ce catalogue
et les définit par le l'éditeur de ce
catalogue c'est lui qui règle les choses
et donc nous on fait des échanges entre
nous en tenant compte de cette cote
on se connaît pas mal donc on se garde
des choses entre nous qu'on a une
capsule un peu spéciale en cas ce que tu
la veux
donc on arrive à avoir des choses
originales
certains collectionneurs possède près de
30000 capsule mais être placomusophiles
ce n'est pas une question d'âge tom a le
vent est bien pour la première fois à ce
type de rencontre
c'est son grand père qu'il a unifié à la
placomusophilie j'emmenais à peu près
160 c'est pour usa et j'ai je les adore
parce que ce trou frais les jolies sur
l'agglomération une vingtaine de saint
quentinois les placomusophiles les
collectionneurs se donne déjà rendez
vous l'an prochain
ils y trouveront peut-être leur bonheur
et c'est la fin de ce journal mais tout
de suite vous restez avec nous car vous
avez rendez vous avec wilfrid est riche
et pour une nouvelle édition du 7 8
politique je vous retrouve demain et
vous souhaite une excellente soirée
vous